hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones video all about
the long night and we're gonna have to
do a brief history of a timeline of
major events in the world I don't think
it needs a spoiler alert because we're
talking about things that happen
weh-weh a long time ago before the
events on the show so here we go
there is a new round of the giveaway -
and because the season 5 DVD is coming
out it's gonna be a gift certificate for
the DVD or the blu-ray but you know
whichever one you guys want all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video I'll just
announce the winner whenever I post my
next game of Thrones video so here we go
Jon Snow spoke that ominous warning in
the season 6 teaser it's actually a line
of dialogue that he had already spoken
on the show the long night is coming a
never-ending winter that covers the
entire planet
remember seasons and Game of Thrones the
seasons of planet toasts the the planet
of Game of Thrones that's what they call
the earth and Game of Thrones or
indeterminate I'm sure there's a
scientific explanation for that but
because magic exists in Game of Thrones
gods exist there's a supernatural aspect
that we just haven't learned about yet
hopefully George or Martin will explain
some of the particulars at a certain
point but the bad news is I'm not
expecting the show to spell that out
anytime soon
usually the show finds more value in the
things that it doesn't explain because
it lets us come up with these really
grand ideas in our heads and those are
usually more fantastic than whatever
explanation the show would give us but
in season 1 there's that line of
dialogue oh sweet summer child you don't
know anything of winter speaking
specifically the Sansa character just
like the sole of innocence at that point
winter's coming it's gotten here now Jon
Snow has seen the horrors that are
coming with it hopefully we'll see some
ice spiders - we haven't seen ice
spiders but a lot of the really cool
details about the long night come from
the expanded books so if you really like
Game of Thrones history you should
definitely check out world of Ice and
Fire it's only partially written by
George art Martin but because it does
have his stamp of approval and he wrote
new material for it the stuff that they
talk about is canon - the series and
unlike the main novels it talks about
what happened during that period but is
usually in a roundabout way with
characters thinking about things that
happen because even though the maesters
were created around that period the
validity of history recorded during that
period is kind of in question it's not
like they had digital records or
anything like that in the maesters
didn't become a thing until house
Hightower became their patrons during
the Age of Heroes there are several
mythical people that are said to be the
progenitors of House Stark house
mr. people like Garth greenhand mythical
people that are believed to have lived
around the same time but because dates
are so fuzzy you just have to take it on
faith but they were all the first men
this is before the Andal invasion so we
were talking about 10,000 years ago and
I'll talk about the timeline of major
events in just a second because the long
night is about eight thousand years ago
already you started to see some
inconsistencies but when the wall was
built at the end of the long night by
bran the Builder there was a maester at
the wall and as we learn from Tyrion who
prowls the Citadel looking for
information on dragons not all of the
Citadel's information on history is
complete there's always a lot of missing
books but one of the other big centers
for knowledge in the world that we
haven't seen yet is the place that
Melisandre comes from ash I hopefully
will see it on the show at some point
but I'm not expecting it because it's so
far east but you get the idea even
though people were alive during the long
night recording history a lot of the
history that has survived it today is
unreliable so you're not really sure
what to believe but legends talk about
the last hero the pact with the children
of the forest the value of obsidian in
fighting White Walkers and the minions
of the great other so if history repeats
itself George RR Martin's really big on
history repeating itself in A Song of
Ice and Fire
then thematically a lot of the same
things will be happening there'll be a
hero there'll be an alliance and there
will be a terrible winter that will
descend on Westeros when Daenerys had
the vision in the house of the undying
about standing in the iron throne room
with snow falling and the roof being
torn off like it had been destroyed that
kind of winter winter to King's Landing
will probably come to pass even if it
doesn't go down exactly the way she saw
it visions like recorded history from
the period of the long night 8,000 years
ago are unreliable do not take them
literally when it comes to the history
of the realm though now we have brand
who is capable of weirwood visions in
the weirwoods are some of the oldest
living things on the planet so there
might be a combination of ways in which
the show addresses history like the long
night but the producers the writers
wouldn't tell you about something that
is coming on the show without ever
intending to do it so I do think that we
will see a version of the long night
during season 6 probably just in a
really brief vision remember there's two
more seasons and I feel like they would
say that nuclear winter for the last
season and there's all kinds of
questions about the White Walkers the
great other what their powers are did
they bring the long night or is it just
part of climate change I've already met
world of Ice and Fire it talks about
some of the other big cultures in
history having different tales for what
brought about the long night each one is
kind of a variation on the Ozora high
legend of all the religions in the world
the red God is one of the oldest it's
the one that names Ozora high as its
mythic Savior figure all the other
cultures of the world have similar tales
they just have a different name for a
Zora high in all of them there is a
mythic Savior figure there is something
resembling the long night so do not be
surprised when history repeats itself I
feel like we've all been building
towards this on the show even though
they haven't really explored all these
other cultures in the Westerosi legends
of the long night the last hero was the
person who made contact with the
children of the forest and was able to
learn from them that obsidian would hurt
the White Walkers and that's what turned
the tide in the battle and helped in the
long night so of all the people on the
TV show there's one person Fran who has
already made contact with the children
of the forest or at least one child of
the forest not many of them are left
alive and I also feel like Jon Snow
could be another person to go into the
north and seek their help that's why
last year when people were asking me
like do you think that sir Jorah is azor
Ahai I just I totally laughed I started
laughing so hard if you dig into a lot
of the expanded material that goes way
beyond what old nan talks about in the
long night then that's a lot easier to
guess whose aura hi might end up being
so even if Daenerys winds up bringing
all those Dothraki all the people from
slavers Bay her dragons everybody from
the east to fight in the war for the
dawn I still feel like history's going
to repeat itself and things will go down
relatively the similar way like the
azure high the mythical savior figure
will be the one to treat with children
of the forest and learn all about White
Walkers here's my big question for you
guys let me know in the comments who do
you think Azure 'hi is and do you think
that we're going to see a vision of the
long night in season 6 it kind of feels
disingenuous for them to tell us about
it and then I'd show it like when they
showed us the dragon eggs in season one
we saw actual dragons in the season
finale so if you're gonna tease the long
night I feel like you have to show it in
a vision sometime during season six but
I'd be really surprised if they sped
things up super fast and we actually saw
it snowing in King's Landing
I'm not expecting that to happen this
season maybe they'll tease it in the
finale
witches were fun here's a brief history
of the realm mostly focused on Westeros
in the east before the coming of the
first men the children of the forest
inhabited Westeros that was more than
twelve thousand years ago the first men
supposedly invaded Westeros about 12,000
years ago crossing using the arm of
Dorne that led to a war between the
first men and the children of the forest
at the end of which the children of the
forest shattered the arm of Dorne using
their magic than about 4000 years after
that the others emerged from the lands
boys winter and thus began the long
night they don't really give a timeline
they just say that the long night lasted
for a generation
so you could say hundred years you could
say sixty years around the end of that
the wall was built the Nights Watch is
founded the thirteenth Lord Commander
becomes the mythical night's king
there's no real official date on that
but then about two thousand years after
that the Andals founded the faith of the
seven and over the next two thousand
years the Andals invaded Westeros and
started conquering all the First Men
about a thousand years after the Andal
invasion the Valyrian freehold rose up
the Valerians tame dragons and conquered
the east then 120 years before Aegon's
conquest the Targaryens migrated to
Dragonstone after one of a naar
Targaryen daughters had a vision of the
doom of Valyria the actual doom of
Illyria didn't happen until about eight
years after their migration then about
three hundred years before the stuff
that's happening on the show right now
was Aegon's conquest Aegon conquered the
Seven Kingdoms realized six kingdoms
because he wasn't able to conquer Dorne
they didn't become an official part of
the kingdom till much much later and
that by no means is like a complete
grant history of the realm but but it's
a pretty big picture of some of the
bigger events there's a lot of really
interesting stuff that they spell out in
the novels so depending on what the show
does I'll definitely do more bonus
videos for the big events in history I
know you're all wondering when the full
trailer is coming for season six a lot
of people think that it's gonna be the
date that DVD is released that's on
March 15 so it's a couple weeks away but
that's the most likely candidate for the
first full season six trailer with
actual footage from season six I know
that seems a long ways away but there's
plenty of Game of Thrones Season six
stuff happening they've been doing a
better job of marketing the show this
year than they did last year why guys
wait for my next video you can click
here for all my Game of Thrones Season
six videos and you can click here to
catch up on Walking Dead before
tonight's episode thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you